[Music]
what's up everybody
Jared again today we're talking about a
show that's definitely gonna get us
demonetized on YouTube
berserk based off the manga of the same
name berserk is one of the oldest
ongoing series out there the anime
premiered in 1997 before going on in
almost 20 year hiatus and has returned
with a controversial new animation style
since the show is still going we can't
quite decipher the entire message here
so while guts quest for revenge against
the god hand and Griffith deals with
some fairly obvious themes ranging from
religion to free will we're gonna leave
that for a future video instead we're
here to talk about the most visually
obvious and philosophically subtle
aspect of the show that's right
berserks metric crap-ton of violence
welcome Liz wisecrack edition on the
philosophy of violence in berserk and as
always spoilers ahead now I know it
might seem like the phrase mindless
violence was coined to describe berserk
but what's going on beneath the surface
of its BDSM inspired angels and gruesome
deaths is actually pretty smart
berserk is unique not only in how it
uses violence to horrify and mesmerize
us but also to transform us to
understand the violence in berserk we
need to consider its genre while the
influences of psychological horror
cosmic horror and even Gore porn can be
seen in berserk the show specifically
rests in horrors monster sub-genre
according to a site assist no Carole
monster horror has two very important
implications one horror as a genre
affords us a critical distance allowing
for a safe space for fascination to take
root simply put violence in real life is
bad but violence on screen is kosher too
the monsters depicted on screen embody
what Carole calls categorical violation
they defy traditional categorizations
and simultaneously attract and repulse
for the same reason it's these two
points that make berserk so well
preserved why are we okay with
witnessing guts literally slice people
in half because we view this
over-the-top violence from a safe
distance and why do we find these awful
acts of violence so compelling because
violence in the show like its subject
matter to
traditional categorizations this
blurring of typical categories and the
fascination and repulsion that it
generates is berserks calling hard these
binaries can be distinctions between
life and death such as when guts mows
down a group of animated skeletons or
the distinction between man and beast in
the Apostles but they can also be less
literal for example father mows goose
head bulging sadist extraordinaire
claims to be an agent of God but is
actually serving the demons he and his
ragtag team of tortures even gain wings
as if they're literally angels lady far
niece now seeing the truth behind her
order realizes what they actually are
[Music]
even guts the epicenter of the show's
violence embodies this idea of
categorical violation he's both a
murderer and a hero an object of
religious prophecy and an anti religious
Crusader in the original anime guts is
branded as a ritual sacrifice for the
god hand a moment that was supposedly
preordained what more does she know
Cotto don't eat she's immortal but guts
managed to defy fate and survive guts is
simultaneously an object of religious
prophecy and a middle finger against
faith or as far Dees originally sees him
[Music]
[Music]
and how God sees himself good day you
thought I just thank you my duty killed
and I did it okay and much like the man
himself guts as violence possesses this
trademark sense of categorical violation
it repels us yet attracts us its
animalistic yet refined this is most
apparent when guts puts on the Berserker
armor and blurs the line between man and
beast his armor even transforming to
mirror this change as guts releases a
savage cry in charge as the battlefield
you can't help but notice the compelling
choreographed ferocity here as his
opponent grun belt notes and when guts
delivers the final blow of the first
bout he does so with a grace that is
more than anything well beautiful while
it might seem strange
according to thinker joel black and act
of violence can in fact be beautiful in
his book the aesthetics of murder he
writes if any human act evokes the
aesthetic experience of the sublime
certainly it is the act of murder if
murder can be experienced aesthetically
the murderer can in turn be regarded as
a kind of artist a performance artist or
anti artist whose specialty is not
creation but destruction of course we're
not giving the thumbs up to murder
but blacks point is that when performed
with the right crafts style and force
violence can have an almost transcendent
effect on its viewers this idea that
something can leave us in awe and
transcend understanding is what
philosopher Immanuel Kant referred to as
the sublime or the State of Mind created
when a certain experience stops being an
object of our judgment and starts
controlling it starting to sound
familiar like monster [ __ ] the sublime
has the power to violate the purpose in
respect of the judgment and to do
violence to the imagination it works
through a process of categorical
violation breaking down the
ian's between our commonly held beliefs
so how does the sublime in berserk
transform us by forcing us to reconsider
our traditionally held ideas
specifically beauty throughout both the
new series and the 1997 version we are
bombarded with intensely violent images
that are in their own way beautiful
when Griffith and his band of heroes or
monsters liberate ver Tanis from the
invading who sean's Griffith seer Sonia
comments on the aftermath here the
senseless death and destruction wrought
by Griffiths army overwhelms Sonia
possessing a beauty that challenges her
very idea of what he is through tapping
into the sublime violence in berserk
frequently becomes a vehicle for change
Sonia opening her eyes to the dazzling
death brought by Griffith leaves her old
life in the village behind and follows
Griffith on his journey to become God
king but berserk is very careful to make
sure it doesn't depict all violence as
evoke in this sense of awe in fact the
show juxtaposes the artful killing of
guts and Griffith with ordinary violence
seemingly common to everyday life
whether it's the villagers stoning
someone to death or a knight whipping a
prostitute from the comfort of his horse
these moments are strangely mundane
Petty and underwhelming in the end these
figures institutions lack the skill and
artistry to evoke the sublime if skill
and craftsmanship are the keys to a
voguing total awe and wonder then guts
can be viewed as something like a
violent performance artist so what's the
effect of guts as visceral and bloody
art does it have a greater purpose or is
it just as French writer Te'o feel gutsy
a calls art for art's sake while it
might be tempting to think it's the
latter guts as acts of violence do have
a greater purpose demonstrating the
hideous nature of the societal violence
and ultimately disrupting it through the
distinction between artistic and non
artistic acts of violence the show
glorifies those that work against the
grey
of society contrasting them with the
drab cruelty of the institution's
themselves a prime example is Griffith
when he's reborn into the world
fulfilling the wishes of the egg of the
perfect world to upend the world order
kono sekai eva americans in de new GE
Kakashi no Tommy no Tokyo sana khan tami
custom image data Rita Gmail image stats
to Joe sustain Uganda julia nation huge
skin touch true to this cause Griffith
and his army take back for Tanis in this
instance Griffith is working against
society his upstart rebel army housing
the coup Shawn's in one fell swoop but
once Griffith reinstates the holy seized
control of the city he becomes enmeshed
in the established power structure
typical to the violence perpetrated by
institutions Griffiths violence
afterwards becomes tasteless and crude
when guts and company arrive later at
the city they find hundreds of slave
traders hanged as enemies of the state
far from possessing Beauty this scene is
sterile methodically organized and
revolting tashieka unlike griffith
though gut says violence is never part
of a greater societal system guts fights
only for himself making enemies out of
whole armies religions and even godlike
beings in fact the bran done guts his
neck attracts demons and apostles
continually forcing guts to abandon
society in the first episode guts
attempts to reenter society by agreeing
to take a carriage ride with a kindly
man and his daughter guts falls asleep
only for his brand to attract demons who
slaughter the father/daughter duo
instead guts his cursed to live and act
on the peripheries of society his
violence becomes a destructive force
upon the world
lady far niece realizes this when she
becomes disillusioned with the Holy See
has all hell breaks loose on the
battlefield
guts is violence invoking the sublime
becomes a powerful force that disrupts
the status quo and forces people to
renegotiate their core ideals for
Farnese this results in her abandoning
her post and even her God in tying
artistic violence to the individual and
unartistic violence to society berserk
is challenging us on where we focus our
attention while we're drawn to be
shining brilliance of guts as violence
or seemingly blind to the everyday
violence that takes place in the greater
world of berserk we as viewers live for
the battle scenes the crystallization of
violence but this ignores the existence
of structural violence or the idea that
certain power structures can prevent
less powerful groups of people from
meeting their basic needs true to form
look who gets screwed over by society in
berserk
each adoro is essentially forced into
servitude being the glorified busboy of
a mercenary group Casca essentially a
mental invalid is singled out for death
by father Mo's goose and almost raped by
a strange fertility cult thing and luka
and her gaggle of young friends are
forced to risk their lives by working as
prostitutes at the base camp
both servicing military officers while
simultaneously fearing those very
officers judgments berserk is
challenging our ideas of what peace
really is we like to think that peace
begins when the battle stops when guts
has finished putting his opponents
through the proverbial blender but
because we can't take our eyes away from
his dazzling acts of violence committed
by guts and others we're unable to
notice or care about all the other acts
of violence committed by society it's in
the lols between battles when berserk
decides to show us the artless and
repulsive violence in the world around
them in these rare moments when we see
people stoned to death or mountains of
dead bodies or even a lake of blood and
entrails we see the limitations of
thinking that piece is simply the
absence of war or battle but for all
those complex intellectual ideas we
don't blame you if you only remember
berserk as the anime were an anthro
morphic horse licks a semi-naked
and there goes the last of our youtube
adsense revenue thanks for watching guys
peace thanks for watching wise crack if
you're hungry for more berserk look no
further than our friends over at verb
that's vrv they want to give you seven
days free to check out all the shows
they've got to offer made by the fun
folks over at crunchyroll Verve is a
mega service that gives you unlimited
access to channels like crunchyroll and
Funimation so you can instantly watch
all the best anime sub and up including
Dragon Ball super my hero academia black
clover boruto food wars season 3 and of
course berserk and if you think that
sounds great Verve is giving wisecrack
fans 7 days of free HD ad free viewing
for all 10 of their channels and when
you order the combo pack you get
everything that includes shudder where
you can get your horror fixed and verbs
select or you can check out season 1 of
Harmon quest and then get the first
episode of season 2 for free new
episodes of season 2 launched at 3 p.m.
Pacific on Fridays so head over to Verve
Co slash wisecrack or click the link in
the description to get your free 7-day
Verve combo pack you can get it on your
desktop on their mobile app Roku
PlayStation and Xbox and thanks to Verve
for sponsoring this video and we've got
tons of great stuff on the way including
videos on the emoji movie and the
prestige so be sure to subscribe if you
haven't already that's all for now catch
y'all next time peace